moment of the sexual experience would
ask the young lady who's your daddy
this should be remixed if officer akimov
is watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here
uh that's beautiful
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
manning
[Music]
a long-legged mcdaddy is the most
successful
on planet earth to reverence the word of
god
to trust it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lies
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
george bush singer and george bush jr
have been penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong i didn't do it that's not my
problem
i got down on my
[Music]
and tons and tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money
and tons and tons of lives
and loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done
except they've done it with semen that
certainly
seems to be a story that has been missed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
flowers
if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his face off
explaining to us why trump really won
the election again
inspectors every state
almost every approved this was thrown
away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not chilled out
from wait he's saying there was a dead
person
in the envelope rudy is about to have
actual
drops of sweat coming off of his brow i
mean is this a normal amount i don't
know how hot it is in the room but this
something seems
very wrong here we'll be in the lawsuit
that comes out duty's melting
arizona is okay as a state that we're
looking at very very carefully
strongly looking at it i would say we're
probably i assume
she's working if she's working for them
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time you should have had
the time and energy to go look for that
[Music]
that's your job like it's my job to
defend the president
i don't represent the president it's
lane michigan
wisconsin is he bleeding did you see is
he bleeding from his ear
what on earth was that needed
to find out this is that hair dye
is to look at the lawsuits in order to
do it it looks like blood
at least and we're getting he's gotta
get off the stage and there are other
aspects of this fraud
on the morning of development someone's
gotta get him a napkin they were gonna
count
this
i've never seen anything like this what
on earth it's getting onto his shirt now
and it was kind of any jury would accept
if they heard this evidence
that somebody had this plan this is
insane maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making
syrup should the city describe that to
you oh my god
it's all over his face he's gonna need a
towel dealing with
evidence i don't know guys it's sounding
like trump won isn't it based on this
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we have
quite a day
ahead of us um i actually my main thing
today is i am covering this
upcoming emergency white house coveted
19 response team press briefing
a number of reporters at the last press
briefing asked
why hasn't the covet 19 team been
briefing us
um so the white house has responded to
that and they've scheduled a briefing
for 20 minutes from now
the regular press briefing was delayed
by
two and a half hours if you can imagine
that imagine if i had been waiting to
cover that
at 1 pm eastern time today that's going
on
and we may look at a little bit of that
in a moment
but i have so many things to cover and
so many things to talk about and we will
be hearing from dr fauci who
somehow he's just a doctor but he's
enemy number one for a lot of these
right-wingers and we're going to be
hearing from him presumably and many
others
rochelle wilensky others at the top of
the hour okay
so welcome everybody you have missed
nothing yet
the announcement has not yet happened i
do want to say thank you to
farsath weather boxer artistic
simplicity
and charison for signing up at uh via
twitch prime
we actually have something very special
today um
we have a broader goal of 100 website
members and twitch subs
if we get to 50 i will play a couple of
rounds of our exclusive new game
gnome chomsky or bobby fisher this is a
game that's been under development for
some time
i was not going to debut it until later
until after our vacation actually but
because the game is ready if we were to
get to
50 just halfway i will play like two or
three rounds of this game with you guys
it's a good game it's a really good game
one of the first games we've developed
and it's very strong very very strong so
that's
let's get to 50 you can use the coupon
code myhipa
at joinpakman.com that's not my rhino
it's not my giraffe it's not my dog
it's my hipaa that's the code and it's
got to be spelled correctly
um and if we get to 50 i'll play i'll
play a few rounds of that
i think people are really going to like
it i think it's going to be fantastic
thanks to uh deeper shades of house our
friend lars baron roth for the raid with
25 people great to have you here
and we've got a lot of different things
going on um jay bundy via super chat
says that dude from the video totally
looks like a senior version of roy wood
jr
i don't know who that is roy wood jr
uh oh pastor james david manning oh okay
yeah i do see a resemblance there yep i
do see a resemblance
we also have uh potentially
oh thanks to kauff drop for the twitch
prime sub
i also have potentially some voicemails
to play for you i'll just preview one to
give you a sense of what they're like
so i was wondering how easy the bible
makes it for
another country to come in and take over
right
like just the continual praise of like
that you would take in somebody else's
orders
okay so there's still a lot that we're
we're still working through voicemails
from the vacation
at the end of june if you can imagine
that
um and then also i will do unban
requests
oh which i don't even have any to do
actually okay so maybe no unban requests
today
let's get into a couple of different
things that i did have
um here is i'm going to cover this in
more detail tomorrow
this is pastor greg locke from the
global
vision bible church in somewhere in
tennessee
tennessee is very heavily infected and
he is screaming at people saying don't
get the vaccine check this out
i've been right about all of it
we've been right about all of it
whoa he's literally doing the sermon in
its circus ten
yes
[Applause]
yes these wicked fools don't win in the
end
they don't win in the end
[Applause]
so all this fear bullcrap is that it is
bull crap say amen
i know you've never been to a church
where pastor told you to say amen after
i said bull crap
whoa edgy this guy must be saying really
interesting things
okay it's better than what i want to say
i call it real bs biblical stupidity
[Music]
biblical stupidity
so i know i wasn't gonna say nothing
about it but i think i feel froggy
enough i'm gonna jump right now and just
say this
okay now he's gonna really talk turkey
i am not apologizing for what i said on
this platform last week
though okay the delta variant was
nonsense then
it is nonsense now you will not wear
masks in this church
you will not wear masks this guy banned
masks
in this church i'm telling you right now
do not get vaccinated
do not get vaccinated i don't care what
you think about me
i don't need your money i don't know how
would he make money from vaccination
anyway it doesn't make sense
this guy's clearly vaccinated right well
i don't need more people on social media
is this a stroke is this a medical event
follow me
i ain't following along with it joe
biden's days are numbered
i've told you the whole time this
election was fraudulent
we got so much proof the only people
that can deny it are crack-smoking
demon-possessed leftists
[Applause]
now that's a church so they don't pay
taxes
right this is a this is such a holy
place
where this is going on that they
have a very special relationship with
the government where they are tax exempt
they receive money from their
congregants and they don't pay taxes
they can own
property and not because it's a church
guys it's a revered place of holy
so you know right so they
do not pay taxes in the united states
very very important stuff
um so that's uh
that's really bad really really bad
um aaron washington dropping a 50
super chat apparently on the way out of
politics maybe as a result of that video
aaron says i'm sorry david but i've
completely 100
given up on america we are deeply
divided along party lines the rich are
still hostile
towards the poor and working class
there's been no meaningful action on
climate change
not fixable so aaron's basically done
and uh i i understand the sentiment my
friend i understand the sentiment it's
it's really bad out there jay bundy says
i wanted to donate more money to support
my to show my support of the previous
super chat
america is in a sad state it's hard to
be hopeful yes
super chats morning america
deretan said fitting that this is
happening in a circus tent yeah it's
it's all bizarre it's all bizarre it
really is
um it's it's crazy
thanks to dollar batteries as well as
tactipus and
nuevo leon for signing up via twitch
prime
number seven uh five six six seven and
eight
i do have a game to play that game is
gnome chomsky or bobby fisher who said
it
and i am we were not scheduled to play
this game until after our vacation
but i'll preview a little bit of it
today if we get to 50.
obviously if we get to 100 phone lines
open and fireworks go off
but even if we just get to 50 we will we
will play a little bit
of this game i think it's a great game
really really good game
um the gen saki press briefing started
two and a half hours late
so we are um we are just kind of
monitoring that because i think the
covet briefing will start
right after this so we're keeping an eye
on that although it is not the main
thing today not the main thing today
hi david when you read physical physical
books do you take notes or remember what
you read
i don't i take i i rarely take notes
when i read non-fiction i will sometimes
underline really really strong
underlining with a felt tipped pen
uh now with with any kind of pen doesn't
really matter
okay so we've gotten that
let's uh oh yeah now what's the oh
lindsey graham with covid yeah let's
look at that so lindsey graham has
coveted lindsey graham test positive for
covet 19.
senator lindsey graham of south carolina
republican said monday he has tested
positive for covid19 despite being
vaccinated
why it matters graham emphasized that
the mildness of his symptoms
is due to being vaccinated
if he had been unvaccinated his symptoms
would be far worse he said
that's uh most of what we know let's see
what he tweeted
i was just informed by the white house
visit by the house physician
i have tested positive for covid19 even
after being vaccinated
i started having flu-like symptoms
saturday night and went to the doctor
this morning
i feel like i have a sinus infection and
at present time i have mild symptoms i
will be quarantining for 10 days
i am very glad i was vaccinated because
without vaccination i am
certain i would not feel as well as i do
now
my symptoms would be far worse well
good good that lindsey graham was
vaccinated good that he got tested
good that he will be quarantining and uh
he is advocating for vaccination that's
exactly right
in the meantime the covet situation in
the united states
is looking very very ugly as you can see
here
we did get up over one hundred thousand
new cases on satur sun friday
um now increasingly there's the belief
that cases are less relevant as more and
more people are vaccinated to some
degree of course that's true
unfortunately this is hospitalizations
and those are also starting to
increase pretty significantly a little
bit of a flattening but that may have
been
our artifact of the weekend but uh
hospitalization's up about a third
and then deaths all also starting to
climb a little bit but not that much so
we were down to
i guess about uh low twos and now we're
back up to
low threes um so we're going to keep
looking at all of that that's what's
going on and part of that is why
we are expecting a briefing from the
white house in about 10 minutes
oh yeah we should talk about florida a
little bit
florida now frequently
um setting new records as you can see
florida set
their single day case record on saturday
with 21
683 new cases in one day
florida has an aggressive spike going on
florida also with record
hospitalizations
and florida's deaths also more than
doubling they had bottomed out at about
22
and they are now back up to 55 um
more than doubling deaths per day in
florida so this is all happening
it is overwhelmingly the unvaccinated
that are dying and we know why that is
the vaccines even though less effective
in terms of preventing infection against
the delta variant
are still very effective in terms of
preventing really serious cases and in
particular
deaths so america number one once again
um from the standpoint of cases
patrick reilly says sir i am positive
pastor locke does not speak at that same
volume to each of his family members all
day long yeah probably not
probably not i want to say thank you to
fendino
as well as amber amber wamber
who says via twitch prime i don't wish
harm on anyone but auntie masters and
anti-vax people get on my nerves
i'm in rural or rural west uh virginia
not west virginia virginia
and in order to protect my family from
plague rats we've kept to ourselves
thank you for the coveted coverage thank
you
also thanks to she for signing up via
twitch prime putting us
at 11. you can take advantage
today of a massive
discount on my website joinpakman.com
that code is my hipaa
it gets you 70 off and as i've stated
if we get to 50 meaning we're only 39
away
we will play three rounds of a new game
we've developed gnome chomsky or bobby
fisher who said it we have chomsky and
fisher quotes
we will put up a quote i have not seen
these yet that i am playing the game as
well as you are
and we will try to figure out who said
it was it chomsky or fisher it's just a
joke it's just because they you know the
beards that's all it is
but i think it would be a really good
game and i'm told my team has put it
together in a way
that it actually will work really really
well so we'll play that game if we get
to 50
phone lines open at 100.
let's listen to a couple of other
voicemails before we get to some more
things
so i don't think if that diet and
exercise um
will prevent the infection or spread of
disease i think it's like a business
called vitamin question
so the way that um nutrition is
explained in personal training
is that there are some foods which have
like empty calories
um yes for every
uh story that you can find a of a nurse
who is anti-vaccine
who you claim to have died of colon um
there are also news reports of people
who were perfectly fine
and then they had the vaccine and then
they became ill
and dying so no that is a lie that is a
lie
hello david pakman i'm calling in
response
to your video about
mr banks and jim jordan being denied on
the committee because of democrats the
reason is
um that you are pushing the big lie that
jim jordan
of ohio who has 100 000 more
integrity than a person like yourself
his integrity points are 100 000 more
than me
he's also a level 72 mage um
we'll not allow the democrats to use
this one day
event of confusion
and um use it as a democrat party
wishes too as a charade too smooth yeah
it's not even clear what he's talking
about
these just come in all day and all night
so i don't understand how like men
like the recent uh man on your talk show
um i don't understand how
when men are talking about loonies or
whatever
and they're like well i don't know how
to deal with them and i blow up
and like i swear and like all this kind
of stuff and i don't know how to deal
with them
and it's like if there was a girl who
said that
she would be like balloony i don't even
know what that's about
uh i feel like if men want to talk about
normal in terms of like being able to
communicate with like different people
and stuff like that without swearing
that's normal from the standpoint of
communication like that's normal
like if somebody who's obviously crazy
and obviously ill
starts saying something and you start
treating them like i just know
these come in all night
so i was wondering about um
bernie sanders as far as like how he
targeted millionaires
and now he's a millionaire right that's
a really big issue
but when it comes to bernie he's a
stereotypical
looking rich white dude he does not look
like a minority
and also it's like leave it up to a
person like that
who looks like that to discriminate
yeah so i was wondering if she could
possibly
find out for political reasons um how
much money goes into
obesity like out of all these like
really extremely fat people with like
all these busy city issues and health
issues and stuff like that
like yeah no of course i want to say
thank you to vhs for sending oh no hold
on let's see
chris says not politics but curious have
you ever had interest in learning
another language if so which one yes the
language was english i was interested in
learning english and when i moved to the
us
i learned it spanish was my first
language english
my second language i started learning
french and middle school and i have
pretty good conversational french
and then i also have a little bit of
hebrew a little bit of hebrew
um and then italian and portuguese are
just easy to understand because they're
so similar to spanish
at this point not like when i went to
italy last i just spoke spanish
and the other person spoke italian
slowly and we could really understand
each other just fine
it was not a problem vhs says at this
point not getting vaccinated is like not
paying your taxes it's highly
irresponsible
yeah well the difference is not paying
your taxes is illegal
mike says david good news merc released
a statement last week saying it's likely
they will have an oral antiviral pill by
the end of 21
also i'm not a spokesperson for merck
just wanted to tell you the news yeah i
figured i think
a real spokesperson for merck would
spell merck correctly but that is great
news if if true
bay photo says according to cnn's manu
raju graham was in attendance at a
houseboat party hosted by joe manchin
this weekend
mansion went on some sunday shows too
yeah maybe mansion has it
manchin i think was on a show along with
aoc
like not at the same time but they
passed each other in the hallway so
lindsey graham's case seems to be
getting very close to aoc
i want to say thank you to iici wfn
johnny 503 as well as lawful waffle for
signing up via twitch prime numbers 12
13
and 14. we will open the phone lines if
we get to 100.
the best way to support is always join
pacman.com that's the place to do it
and you can use the coupon code myhipa
to get a
big big discount looks like there's a
few people on the website
clicking around struggling to get the
coupon codes working at this point in
time
um okay
let's continue and listen to a few more
we are eventually going to get to
voicemails from
other people we're just going through a
lot of them from the same few callers
right we're going in order as i've
promised
hey david um
i kind of just uh i figured i just call
you
um to tell you about something going on
it's relevant to your show
in my family i honestly don't know who
else to talk to
at this point right now but my
father has been sick
recently just suddenly sick i can't
remember the last time he was sick
and i said to my mother well d
sorry i'm talking loud i'm a little
upset but i said do you think it's coded
she said well i don't know it's been a
little while i'm like what do you mean
like well
a little over a week i said oh well you
know thanks for telling me
because i come by here a lot dear god
mostly just to see my dad
and uh well they're trump supporters
so they didn't get no dang vaccine i got
the vaccine
i'm not a trump supporter but they are
and they're not going to get that
vaccine they don't believe in it
and i am terrified
because my dad is almost 70 years old
he's still working he's he might have
coveted i am
horrified that he might have kobe so you
should get tested the only one i got
in my family he's the only one i really
talk to
i yeah so that's a tough situation
that's a tough situation uh oh it looks
like then he called back
hey david it's uh chuck again um i was a
little upset earlier i didn't
wasn't able to leave a good message but
um just basically like my parents are
both trump supporters
um they didn't get the vaccine they
didn't really
uh they weren't believing in covet very
much yeah and now suddenly my dad is
sick
he's my camera last time it looks like
he's going over the exact same stuff
yeah no so that's uh that's not good
just think it's a really bad idea that
we
blame china who's like has people
enslaved
like in general i don't think that it's
a good idea to blame asians
because of how many people so many
asians
are enslaved yeah yeah yeah don't blame
asians that's an interesting take
i was thinking about um standing up for
myself
against these transgender surgeries
yeah okay okay okay skip exactly
also let me quit telling people what to
do with their bodies who the hell do you
think you are
you little [ __ ] piece of worm
to tell people that they have to do
something who the hell do you think you
are you liberal
to try to mandate and force people
to put this clinical trial
junk garbage into their bodies you are
a slimy dirtbag human being
yeah things are pretty backwards you
know we're trying to save people and
we're the evil guys
again david pakman you only report on
supposedly the
people who knows that they even are
dying of colbin
but um anyone who's anti-vaxxed that
dies
um you and the global corporate
mainstream media are quick to report on
it but
once again you ignored the people who
are dying who are relatively healthy
and were brainwashed or forced by their
employer
to take the vaccine who are dying of
vaccines yeah that's not happening
unfortunately for
for uh troy's narrative
hello this is whitney um i just
i was looking at this thing called
swiss and i didn't see you on there it's
like all these celebrities and stuff
like that they have uh
books and stuff like that that um yes
i'm not on
slist whatever that is
so i was thinking about um to kind of
like
save our souls in general to keep the
focus
on the environment as far as politics
because i'm feeling
like anything like sexual related is
seeking like this really
extreme like from point
center wow
so one of the questions i had about the
environment
uh was how is it going to be progressive
because these are all voicemails coming
every few minutes just so people know
so this is whitney again i really think
that you should check out this
app called flis f-l-i-i-s-t
um i'm looking right now at obama's
reading list
it like told me a lot about kind of like
what was going on
uh he had a book on capitalism
um that he said really shine the light
yeah on the last year a ton of
voicemails huh yeah big massive dumps
maybe just like one more
um i was just thinking that we should
elect a bernie because i feel like
maybe oh now she likes bernie the
previous
few voicemails back bernie was bad
skills could be
a good attribute just be
like i feel like he would be able to be
used
um very versatility
i don't know if that's a word i don't
think it is namely
i just want him to like versatility is a
word but that's not
the word she meant okay all right so
we're going to move on from that
um yeah maybe maybe we'll get back to
that
the white house press briefing has ended
so now the next up event
is the covet briefing very very
important stuff
i want to say thank you to halibut fish
for subscribing with twitch prime i
really do appreciate that you're number
15
and a big thank you
wow jeff hyatt signing up on my website
with the code
myhipa jeff thank you for signing up you
are new member number 16
the coupon code myhipa it does crazy
things whatever you're lacking in your
life
the code myhipa will provide you and as
i mentioned if we get to just
50 100 is the big goal and we should be
able to do it but if we just get to 50 i
will play a few rounds of a new game we
have
chomsky or fisher no who said it the
game is
who said it noam chomsky or bobby
fisher now just to preview it for you
okay
here's here's a game all right here's a
quote
this is the way the game would work it's
an exclusive game if i had a minute with
george bush i'd ask him if he's talked
to god lately
who said that was it gnome chomsky
or was it bobby fisher that's this is
the gist of the game
if we were playing it right now i would
play a video clip and then we would all
learn who said it okay now people are
saying oh it's easy it's easy it's easy
i've been told the whole point of the
game if the game is set up not to be
easy
okay so if people are interested in that
before we go on vacation and then we
have to wait you know six months
before we play this game today is a good
day to do it
i want to say thanks to jen here for
gifting two subs via twitch putting us
at 18.
uh people seem to be liking the game
people seem to be liking the game
all right a few other super chats coming
in matthew says fauci is going to
announce mission accomplished and say
covet is over right
somehow i doubt it somehow i doubt it
chris says even if you don't watch it on
stream there's an amazing animated
depiction of sam cedar and crowder
debate
stephen crowder's nightmare on youtube i
did hear about that
uh let's take a look at it
steven crowder's nightmare
let's see here yeah here it is let's
check it out just a little bit of this
whoop that's not it
crowder's nightmare
here it is
okay
right all right let me check this
[Music]
okay
all right okay i'm really glad to have
my next guest on the show and i've
always said this i always respect
people who um enter the enter into the
arena
um and you know we've had a lot of
debates on this show which is different
from like a change my mind where we sit
down with conversations
but i have to appreciate the guy making
the time because a lot of people haven't
uh
you know some of you like them some of
you don't same can be said for me ethan
klein from
h3h3 uh ethan thanks man for making the
time you're very welcome and i just want
to say i know you called me you said
that i would be a layup
i think i used something like that yeah
and i think you're right because i don't
think i'm a very good debater
i think you know that so i don't want to
make it too easy for you oh okay
so i've prepared okay yes
all right so what we were going to talk
about is uh what we were going to talk
about is
you know the initial quote that happened
i think he's looking off there
uh is ethan supposed to be eating
something during the thing
anyway you guys get the idea um and uh
i'll leave i'll leave the rest of it for
you guys to watch on your own but it's
nicely done it's very nicely done
uh i want to say a big thank you to luke
nitschke
luke just signed up on my website using
the coupon code myhipa bringing us one
closer to the chomsky versus bobby
fisher
game very exciting a game i would love
to play with you today
mind hack says from the standpoint of
massive dumps what would you rate those
voicemails
a lot of those are really low really
really really low
detonation says sir person women
man camera tv exactly
uh rohit nair says anti-science is far
more dangerous than we probably realize
the arrogance of people not wanting to
believe doctors and scientists is
frightening
i actually in i'm doing a commentary
tomorrow that's
related to that and i talk about that
specific aspect the arrogance of it
very very astutely said and i completely
agree with that
i also want to say thank you to
jacqueline grant
jacqueline or jackie i don't know if you
go by jackie has just signed up at
joinpakman.com using the coupon code
myhipa
putting us at 20. that puts us 40
percent of the way
to 50 and 20 percent of the way to 100
and fifty percent of the way to forty
and sixty seven percent of the way to
thirty
how relevant those calculations are i
don't know
but anyway it's something people might
enjoy
something people might enjoy people
asking for unbanned requests i don't i
don't think i have any
let me take a look i didn't at the
beginning of the stream
uh no no no one ban requests today to
adjudicate
i was actually not a math major people i
know thinking that i must be a math
major based on those calculations
but uh no i am not um
all right let's look at let's look at
some generic voicemails okay
thank you i really love watching your
program
i'm a born again christian and i'm in
indiana
thank you so much whoa okay that's not
bad
i like that that's not bad
in cincinnati um apparently some good
news though about 30 days give or take
late uh
we have reached the 70 of uh americans
getting their first shot at minimum
and apparently cnn i think it was i saw
a story um
over 800 people on 800k people yeah so
we've had
20 straight days of the average level of
vaccination
increasing from the standpoint of daily
in the united states that's a really
good thing
i want to say thank you to casey bates
for the twitch prime sub putting us at
21 today
um couple other we're doing
random okay here we go hi
david deborah from portland oregon i
love love love your show i always tell
people about it
question what would it take to get
somebody
like ron desantos out of office
desantis because clearly he is acting in
an insane irrational manner
yeah it seems like there has to be a way
that people can remove him from
office yes voting him out is the way to
do it
that that's really that's really what it
comes down to quite frankly
hi david um my name's logan i'm from
kenosha wisconsin
i was just wondering um
what do you think would happen if trump
ran as an independent
i think he would lose but he would take
away enough votes from the republican
nominee
such that the democratic candidate would
win
hey david uh i was wondering how exactly
is the republican right wing
that complains about cancel culture and
how millennials are just
snowflakes you've been uh coddled to
how is how are they any different how's
that
depiction any different than what they
are actually
showing us with them taking the vaccine
yeah have a good day bye
did anybody understand that i didn't
understand that question
how is millennials in cancel culture and
snowflakes being coddled different
than the depiction that they're having
the vaccine
man i don't know what that means let's
listen let's try it once more
hey david uh i was wondering how exactly
is
the republican right wing
that complains about cancel culture and
how millennials are just
snowflakes you've been uh coddled to
how is how are they any different how's
that depiction any different
than what they are actually showing us
with them taking the vaccine
oh okay so i it's the idea that
republicans claim millennials
are snowflakes who need to be coddled
but in reality
it is the anti-vaxx right wingers who
are really the snowflakes who need to be
coddled because they don't want to get
the vaccine is that
i think is that what it is i think i
understand it
hey david i just want to get your take
on this uh
who you think is a more
dangerous group of people uh those
who think the election was fraudulent or
coveted anti-vaxxers i'll take my
answer off the air thanks pax dog
that's tough i don't i don't know
because so if it were just beliefs
the anti-vaxx the anti-vaxx um
leads to them not getting vaccinated and
it allows kova to continue to spread
just believing the election was stolen
doesn't really it's not dangerous in
itself but then when they go out and
riot you know then it becomes dangerous
i think we're basically talking about
the same people so
i don't know that we really even need to
answer it in those terms
johnny minogue says hi from the beach in
ocean city new jersey hope your vacation
is fantastic thank you i appreciate that
a couple other super chats uh voicemails
rather hi david one of my favorite
recent
segments on your show was when you said
that the problem in the united states is
not that people
can't agree on what are
the facts people can't agree on
what facts are right like what the word
fact
even means yes what constitutes as a
fact and how is that different from
something else
so i gotta ask you david what is a fact
oh god okay yeah we're going to go
hi david this is justin from optional
pennsylvania
i watch your show all the time and
subscribe on youtube
i had a quick theory i wanted to run
past you do you think
that marjorie taylor greene and matt
gates
are kind of doing damage control for
trump right now where
um you know they're going around trying
to
support the the riders um
to kind of save face for trump so that
no no i don't i don't think so at all
um hi david um i just uh i have had
another suggestion i wanted to drop and
see if you'd be
interested in doing something on please
um i i know there was something about
like you living
in in brazil or living living in south
america at some point
oh my god i was curious about um
there's a uh a branch of like christians
that developed in in
in south america uh a type of theology
called liberty
liberation or the liberation theology
and uh
it was really condemned by like the
catholic church and stuff for being like
two socialist
and yeah i never lived in brazil i don't
really know anything about that
but it's something i could make a phone
call about
hi david amy here and i'd like to know
if you could look into what's happened
to the track and trace program
at the beginning they were hiring lots
of people to contact others when they
come into contact
oh forget about that i haven't heard
that mentioned
in forever if you could look into that
and answer my question
i'd appreciate it thanks for doing what
you do bye
yeah i mean it's just you know it's
don't
forget about that forget that it's just
not happening
yo what's up pac maniacs neverfall here
just wanted to uh ask a question about
people's views on abortion when
astronomically it is in favor
of brown people being aborted so
it's really easy to be like i'm
pro-abortion but not really
understands that listen even this
framing is just weird i'm pr
no i've never met anyone in my life
who's pro-abortion
and that they want to get more abortions
to happen
okay i've never ever ever in my life met
anyone okay
so if you want to talk about abortion
disproportionately being
um uh op chosen by non-white people
before we even get to that conversation
pro-abort nobody's pro-abortion it's
should it be legal
if that is what the mother in in
consultation
with medical uh elements of medical
decide that wouldn't probe give me
pro-abortion come on guys
give me a break hey yeah good morning
david my name is
is carlos um out of arizona
i'm kind of just too you know just to
talk to you a little bit about
you know the racism that exists in this
country and kind of
have a uh a colored male
you know goes through this on a daily
basis um recently
you know i worked for a major retail um
actually across the world
had a customer who felt the need to
express to me that i am a colored boy
oh my god i'm a young i'm a grown man
i'm educated
i'm about yours some white male feels
the need to demean me by calling me boy
turn around and i you know respectfully
approached him and told him hey
don't ever speak to me this way don't
ever call me boy again
but i don't know what makes you think
you can refer to people that way
yeah that's crazy this guy goes on a
crazy rant
starts cussing at me start yelling at me
apparently addressing a white male
to be respectful and just letting him
know
to not be mean any employee within our
company
is being rude he went as far as saying
that i was being racist
because i don't let someone speak to our
employees
and refer to them as boys
[Laughter]
right you were the racist for trying to
control his speech yeah
um man that's that's crazy
that's crazy uh
are there any working coupon codes other
than my hipaa i'm having trouble
spelling it yeah
there are there are um
[Music]
let's try here's a coupon code people
might like this is on my website
this this is still probably my favorite
coupon code
indictment 21
there you go that's a hell of a coupon
code
indictment 21 oh yeah immoral 21
let's try that one that one may work
oh six extra cents though
if you go with indictment 21
that'll drop it from a dollar eighty six
to a dollar eighty that's an even better
deal
that's an even better deal i would go
with that definitely
very very much so okay a couple other
super chats
zack foster says i think most degree
masks are a needed precaution in the
meantime there are a ton of confounders
in the massachusetts outbreak
and and odd to base guidance off of yeah
so i
we talked about this on the bonus show
today there's a lot
of really wacky stuff so so for people
who don't know
there was big around the fourth of july
provincetown massachusetts had an event
called
bear week okay which is like a big it's
like a big gay event
oh hold on a second we'll get back to
that and one in three cases nationwide
occurred in florida and texas this past
week
dr williams from the start we've known
that this virus is unpredictable oh my
god here we go
that's why we spent the last six months
preparing for every scenario
as a result we have the tools we need to
manage this most
this most importantly the tool that is
most important
is the highly effective vaccines right
we have enough vaccines for every
american who wants one
they're free and they're easily
accessible within
five miles of ninety percent of where
americans live
and in just six months we've already
gotten 165 million americans fully
vaccinated
including 80 percent of seniors who are
the most vulnerable
but we have much more work to do to put
this pandemic behind us
there are still about 90 million
eligible americans who are
unvaccinated and we need them to do
their part
roll up their sleeves and get vaccinated
each and every shot matters
and last week the president laid out
several areas where we're taking
additional steps to get more americans
vaccinated
we expanded the tax credit to help small
and medium-sized businesses
provide their employees paid time off to
get themselves
and also their families vaccinated
and we're working with school districts
and pharmacies to bring vaccines to
schools to make it as convenient as
possible
for students to get vaccinated
in the past two weeks we've seen a 50
increase
in the average number of 12 to 17 year
olds getting vaccinated each day
yes that's a very encouraging uptick
super strong
we're also working with states to
encourage vaccinations through
incentives
which have made a difference throughout
the vaccination effort donate plasma
this week
the president called on states and local
governments to use funding they have
received including from the american
rescue plan
to give a hundred dollars to anyone who
gets fully vaccinated
oh man minnesota and new mexico have
already stepped up to answer the
president's call
if financial incentives like these help
us get more shots and arms
we should use them
but in addition to incentives it's time
to impose some requirements
based on the realities oh risk here we
go vaccinated
individuals this is the announcement
here we go those who have been
vaccinated let's take some notes
last week the department of veteran
affairs announced it will require
doctors and nurses and other health care
workers who provide medical care
to our veterans to get vaccinated
this is in lockstep with many healthcare
employers around the country who are
requiring vaccinations
and will protect our veterans when they
get medical care
at the president's direction the
department of defense uh-oh
is looking into how and when they will
add covet 19 vaccination
to the list of required vaccinations for
the military wow
and to protect the federal workforce
their loved ones and their communities
the president announced that every
federal government employee will be
asked to attest
to their vaccination status any federal
employee who does not attest
or is not vaccinated will be required to
mask
no matter where they work get tested
once or twice a week
wow socially distance and generally will
not be allowed to travel for work
wow we're taking steps to apply
similar standards to all federal
contractors
it's simple what are those military
dudes going to say when they've they're
told you you got to get vaccinated
or you're out and the president has
called on all employers around the
country to protect their own workforces
and now we're seeing positive momentum
across the private sector
the chamber of commerce the national
association association of manufacturers
and the business roundtable have all
applauded the actions we're taking
companies like google walmart and disney
have announced vaccination requirements
for their employees
joining hundreds of universities and
hospital systems across the country
who are implementing similar
requirements wow
with these ongoing efforts there's a
strong
sense of progress and you see it in the
number of shots we're getting into
people's arms each day
over the past few weeks we've seen a
nearly 70 percent increase in the
average number of new people getting
vaccinated
each and every day in the last seven
days alone
three million americans have gotten
their first shot
that's the highest seven day total since
july fourth
and just today we hit 70 percent of
adults with at least one shot
including 90 percent of seniors with at
least one shot
these are significant milestones in our
fight against the virus
and it's very important to note in the
states with the highest case rates
daily vaccination rates have more than
doubled
the eight states with the highest
current case rates have seen an
average increase of 171 percent
in the number of people newly vaccinated
each day over the past three weeks
louisiana has seen a 302 percent
increase
in the average number of newly
vaccinated per day mississippi
250 yeah guys it's weird like
the the military has had vaccine
requirements for decades and decades
how is it all of a sudden illegal to
include the coveted vaccine on that list
it just it doesn't pass the where were
you on the military anti-vaxx
activism up until an hour ago being
unvaccinated
and responding with action and that's
what's
it's going to take to get us out of this
pandemic
right with that let me turn it over to
dr bolinsky
and dr falchi here we go wilinsky first
this is big
good afternoon let's begin with an
overview of the data
as of saturday cdc reported the
seven-day moving average of daily new
coveted 19 cases
to be about 72 000 cases per day
oh man this represents an increase of 44
from the prior seven day average
and higher than our peak of last summer
the seven day average of hospital
admissions is about 6 200 per day
an increase of about 41 percent from the
prior seven day period
brutal and seven day average daily
deaths have also
increased to 300 per day an increase of
more than 25
from the previous seven day period i
want to start today by simply stating
the obvious
while we desperately want to be done
with this pandemic
covered 19 is clearly not done with us
and so
our battle must last a little longer
many of us have lost loved ones or have
been ill ourselves
all of us have given up things in our
lives that we enjoy
this is hard this is heavy but we are in
this together
and as we learn more about kovid we
continue to rely on
proven ways to protect ourselves our
children
and our loved ones i told you i would
give you scientific information as i
have it
when i have it here is what we have
learned in the last two weeks about the
delta variant
first the delta variant is highly
contagious
to put this in perspective if you get
sick with the alpha variant
you could infect about two other
unvaccinated people
if you get sick with the delta variant
we estimate that you could infect about
five other native people more than twice
as many as the original strain second
infections with a delta variant result
in higher viral loads
this means that those who are infected
have a larger burden of virus that they
can spread
to others third those higher viral loads
are seen
not just in those who are unvaccinated
and infected
but also and importantly in the small
proportion of those who are vaccinated
whoa whoa last week we published data on
an
outbreak in barnstable county
massachusetts where there were 346
confirmed cases of coven 19
in people who were fully vaccinated
during the summer
some towns in barnstable county can have
up to 240
000 visitors per month those with break
for through infections had viral loads
that were similar
to people who were infected and
unvaccinated
this new finding combined with data from
other outbreak investigations and
surveillance studies
across the country was critical in our
decision to
update our guidance for those who are
fully vaccinated
since those data were released several
other studies have been released over
just this past weekend that have
corroborated these findings
taken together the delta variant is
different from prior strains
i understand this is all frustrating
news and i share this frustration
we continue to learn each day from
emerging science
and use this evidence to update our
recommendations
because of what we now know about the
delta variant and infections and those
who are vaccinated
whoa updated our recommendations
including
recommending masks in public indoor
settings in areas with substantial and
high
transmission shown in orange and red
on this map it is also the reason we
continue to recommend
universal indoor masking in k-12 schools
throughout the country
so our children can safely get back to
school
and safely stay there in all of this
there is still good news
our vaccines are working to prevent
prevent severe illness
hospitalizations and death vaccines are
providing protection
both for individuals and communities
across the country
as i have said before this remains a
pandemic of the
unvaccinated where the vast majority of
spread
is in this country is among those who
are unvaccinated
i want to be clear while vaccinated
people can spread the virus if they get
a breakthrough infection
the odds of them getting sick in the
first place are far
lower than those who are unvaccinated
and in fact
places with more vaccination generally
have less disease
we can see this on a population level on
this slide
where we compare case counts and
vaccination coverage by
state with vaccination coverage on the
horizontal axis
and case counts on the vertical axis
states with the highest vaccination
coverage are the dots furthest to the
right on the graph
and states with the highest case counts
are the dots closest to the top
notice that the states that have lower
vaccination coverage those further to
the left
have higher rates she has to explain how
to read this as shown
in red and orange states that have
higher vaccination coverage further to
the right
have lower rates of cases as shown in
yellow
there is a direct correlation with
vaccine coverage
and case rates and i think it's worth
reiterating that public health
prevention strategies
including masks continue to work while
you're unvaccinated
in the following outbreaks of cases in
barnstable county and in subsequent
public health follow-up
we saw the power of vaccines and masks
over the month of july there were a
total of 934
confirmed cases of covet 19 linked to
the outbreak in barnstable county
with 73 of these infections and people
who were vaccinated
there were only seven hospitalizations
and no deaths our vaccines did exactly
what they were supposed to do
prevent severe disease hospitalization
and death
furthermore as cases increased local
public health officials
implemented a package of public health
prevention strategies
including increased testing contact
tracing and
indoor mask wearing and within two weeks
test positivity fell from a peak of 15.1
percent
to 4.6 public health prevention
strategies work let me end by
reiterating three things you need to
know
first our vaccines are working to
prevent severe illness
hospitalization and death a lot of
people getting banned a lot of people
please protect yourself and get
vaccinated
second masks will protect you and your
family
if you are in an area of substantial or
high transmission
please wear a mask in public indoor
settings regardless of your vaccination
status
and third we need to keep our children
safe
and in school get everyone in your
family
over the age of 12 vaccinated and please
wear
masks in school finally we stand here
with you
providing science and updated guidance
in real time
to keep you and your families safe
thank you i'll now turn it over to dr
fauci
thank you very much dr wolinski i'd like
to take up on the theme
that dr wolenski started with if i could
have the first slide i'm going to
be spending a couple of minutes
addressing here we go
issues that are very much on the
attention
of people throughout the country and the
world the first
is as dr walensky mentioned the real
world
effectiveness of vaccines in the context
of the delta variant and second
breakthrough
infections what they mean and let's
discuss them
a bit next slide let's look at the real
world effectiveness
against the delta variant if you look at
the three components
of pcr confirmed infection it's 79
percent in a uk
study symptomatic infection is 88
and just as dr walensky mentioned the
vaccines are doing
exactly what we're asking them to do
when it comes to keeping you
out of the hospital out of serious
disease
and certainly preventing your death just
a quick
comment on the 79 percent
that may look a bit low but remember
the efficacy of the clinical trials that
were published
by the trials that gave you something
like 94 or 95 percent
was against clinically apparent disease
what we're talking about here is just
infection so you would expect it to be
a bit lower this has important
implications
when you get into the discussion of what
we call breakthrough
infections next slide now if you take
these data
and look at them across multiple
countries
but ask the question what does a full
component of a fisa mrna provide
with regard to protection against alpha
versus delta in three separate countries
important
the data on the left are essentially the
data i just showed you
alpha now is in blue and delta is in red
when you get to canada you see a similar
protection against hospitalization which
is the
area a bit to the right in that middle
panel
compared to symptomatic disease right
when you get to israel you see what we
now know
from reports from israel that you see a
diminution
at around 64 percent for confirmed
and symptomatic disease this is likely
due to the fact
that israel has started their
vaccination program
before the other countries so you're
seeing a little bit
down the pike from the beginning but
note again
the 93 percent consistently showing
protection against advanced disease next
slide
now if you ask the question what about
the reduced risk
of either symptomatic infection
hospitalization or death
when you compare vaccinated individuals
with unvaccinated perfect questions what
is the fold
reduction when you're in red with
unvaccinated
versus in blue with full vaccinated
right
as you can see for disease itself it's
an eightfold reduction
for hospitalization 25-fold reduction
and for death 25-fold reduction
let's move on now to break through
infections just a couple of comments
super strong
pass this slide go to the next slide
please
the breakthrough infections we have no
vaccine
is a hundred percent effective and so
you can expect breakthrough infections
so even with a high vaccine
effectiveness
both of these infections are going to be
asymptomatic
or mild and we know that we've already
seen that
from the experience in massachusetts in
provincetown
and we see it in all other situations
an important point to bring up is that
the greater percentage of people that
are vaccinated
even with a high degree of protection
the
absolute number of breakthrough
infections
might appear yes hi that's not the
critical number
right the critical number is what is the
proportion of the vaccinated people
who in fact are uh are getting
breakthrough infections thank you that's
the critical one the bottom line of what
we are saying
is that next slide
get vaccinated i say that every single
time
we all say it the covet vaccines give
strong protection
against the delta variant and it
protects you
your family and your community
thank you doctor thank you thank you dr
faucian thank you dr wolinski
as you both stated it's never been more
important to get vaccinated
that's how we stop the spread of the
delta variant and
each and every shot matters and while we
work to get more people vaccinated the
federal government
is also helping states and communities
respond to outbreaks
since launching our covet 19 surge teams
we've been
working directly with 10 states to
support their efforts to combat
rising cases with federal assistance and
support
last week we reiterated to all governors
that we stand ready to help them in
meeting this moment
whether that be through more testing
increasing treatments
vaccine access and uptake or other
state-specific needs
for example in missouri cdc experts are
on the ground
providing epidemiology data analysis and
other public health support
fema in missouri is helping to expand
ambulance capacity and hhs and fema
are helping the state address their
hospital needs
we're working with states like north
carolina on mobile vaccination clinics
in tennessee on public health staffing
and the administration is doing
extensive outreach in stakes like
like wyoming and arizona to encourage
more physicians to use
life-saving monoclonal antibody
treatments antibody treatments
those are really effective and we need
to deploy them more and more
where they're needed the bottom line is
we're doing everything we can to help
more americans get vaccinated
and to help states fight the spread in
their communities
with that let's take a few questions
here we go first question
jay jeff i i want to just add one thing
one of the slides was deleted uh a
technical if
difficulty that i'd just like to spend
maybe 15 seconds i think it's really
important
when we talk it was mistakenly deleted
and that's the reason why i skipped by
that other slide
when you look at breakthrough infections
as i mentioned
they're expected and are usually
asymptomatic
as of july 26 the cdc received
6587 reports
of breakthrough infections that resulted
in hospitalization or
death among 163
fully vaccinated million people that is
a percentage
of 0.01
or less and when you look at the
breakthrough cases
the percent of breakthrough cases in
multiple locations like dc and virginia
the percent ranges from 0.26
to 0.03 so i'm sorry that was left out
the bottom line is
they are rare and they rarely result
not rarely but unusually result in
hospitalization or death
thanks jeff thank you dr fauci okay
first question please
please keep your question to one
question we're very limited on time jeff
mason reuters
hi thanks very much uh jeff you said
earlier that it was time
to do uh to have requirements with
relation to the vaccine
and then you went on to list basically
what you said last week about the va
and the and the and dod are there more
requirements coming
do you think that there should be more
requirements coming and can you respond
broadly to the impression that you are
playing down
the breakthrough cases thank you good
well i'll take the
the first part of the question and then
i'll turn to dr fauci because he just
talked about
uh breakthrough cases jeff as you know
in the federal government we've now put
forward
a strong system that if you're
vaccinated you can come back to work
as normal if you're not vaccinated there
are quite strict rules that you need to
follow around
testing social distancing and masking
the department of veteran affairs as us
as you said is an example of
a vaccine requirement for all of their
caregivers to our veterans
the president has asked the department
of defense to look into how
they will add cover to the list of
mandatory vaccinations for our
armed forces how and when they would do
that
we will be looking across the federal
government in other areas that could
require these types of mandates if you
will
for vaccination at the same time i think
it's really encouraging that we're
seeing the private sector
follow i mentioned walmart disney and
google
all announcing vaccine requirements and
there's dozens of other
companies that are doing these types of
actions to protect their workers
as they come back to work uh
universities
other health systems so jeff i think
you're going to see a continued
increase in vaccination requirements as
people bring
employees back to work second question
was around breakthrough dr fauci
yeah i'm i'm sorry what was the exact
question about breakthrough jeff i
missed that one
jeff this is jeff zions jeff mason was
asking
are we downplaying in some way the
number of breakthrough
infections that are happening across the
country
no no we're actually not uh jeff jeff
mason that is
i um as i mentioned in
in the discussion when you look at the
numbers the
total absolute numbers when you're
dealing with a cohort
that you're examining that has a very
high percentage
of people who are vaccinated or large
numbers
by definition even with a high degree
of efficacy you are going to see
absolute numbers
that are high the critical issue is
what is the relative number the percent
that i mentioned and that's the reason
why
i apologize i wanted to interject
that slide that was left out to show you
the lower percentage of people who are
in that category
next question please cheryl stollberg
new york times
hi thanks for doing this call a lot of
americans
remain very confused about the
recommendations they don't understand
why
vaccinated people need to start wearing
masks again they're confused about what
this means for their children
in schools and i'm wondering if
you think that your messaging has been
clear enough to the public and what if
anything
are you going to do to try to address
the confusion
and didn't they just explain that
simplify things for
for ordinary americans out there who
don't follow every nuance of this and
the blinging i mean come on
yeah thank you cheryl so maybe i'll
start with the children and say
i think our guidance um is very clear
about what we should be in schools and
that is
everyone who is in a k-12 school um in
the fall should be masked
everyone across the country adults
children
vaccinated or unvaccinated everyone
should be masked
in terms of uh the the question about
guidance for vaccinated people wearing
masks there are
two components to what we're trying to
do here one is we're trying to save
lives with our vaccines and they're
working to do so and that's terrific
what they weren't studied in the
clinical trials as to whether they
prevent transmission
initially they did with alpha
unfortunately they no longer do with
delta
the the good news is that the vaccines
really do work
to prevent getting sick however for
those people who do get
sick we are suggesting um we
the data suggests that you could
potentially transmit and for that reason
we are suggesting both vaccinated and
unvaccinated in areas of
high disease burden orange or red on the
map continue to wear masks so they don't
bring disease
home or to others who are unvaccinated
yeah i would just add that
from day one the president said we would
lead with science
and facts and that continues to be the
approach
and cdc and our other health experts are
doing just that
leading with science and facts we never
said
what's annoying about them asking that
question when it's been explained is it
also suggests
that it hasn't been explained like
because if it did why would you ask the
same question again foundations
next question let's go to aaron billups
at spectrum
hi thanks so much for taking my question
i was wondering how much of any
surveillance
is being done to determine the amount of
asymptomatic spread
experts i've spoken to say not enough of
this is happening
also to help people get a sense of how
much protection
previous coveted infections offer um
that's something i heard a lot of people
point to
as a reason they don't need to be
vaccinated is there any data
there is data about that who had
previous coveted infections and whether
that offered them any protection
okay dr wolinski first and then dr
felicia
great yeah so we have numerous cohort
studies that are examining
exactly that so we have several cohorts
tens of thousands of people across the
country
where uh some of them are actually doing
weekly pcr testing these are cohorts of
essential workers and healthcare workers
so we can actually examine how much uh
is
disease is occurring in people who might
be asymptomatic that is the best
epidemiologic way to study exactly that
question
dr fauci yeah with regard to the second
question
that if you're dealing with the same
variant if you get infected with an
alpha variant or another variant and
that you recover from that you are
pretty well protected for a reasonable
period of time
from re-infection it isn't perfect but
it's it's good protection you can't
doubt that the situation changes when
you're dealing
with the evolution of a new variant such
as
the delta variant and what we are seeing
right now
that there are re-infections the
protection you get from
the original infection still exists
somewhat
but re-infections occur at a much
greater rate
among individuals now than we did
against the original alpha so
bottom line is when you're dealing with
a variant you don't get
the kind of protection that you would
have hoped to have gotten
from a previous infection regarding the
issue of vaccinating
people there's no doubt when you
vaccinate someone
who has had an original infection and it
was recovered
not only do you increase the depth of
the
of the protection not only do you
increase the duration
but you also increase the breadth of it
so that you cover not only the original
but the variance and that's the reason
why the recommendation still holds that
even though you've been
infected previously in the context of
variance
it's a good idea to get vaccinated
anyway
next question
go to rachel kors at stat news
um hi there i had a question for um
director valenci
about you know whether the cdc is
tracking
um kobit 19 booster shots that may be
authorized by physicians
um we are just thank you for that
question rachel we are just
starting to um gather data and get data
on uh and we can discern between people
who have gotten
uh second and third shots we are uh
trying hard to encourage people to
report on the safety side
if people have taken the initiative to
get their third shot again not yet
recommended
um but we have the capacity and are
looking at those data right now
wow dr fauci anything to add there no
nothing to add she said it very well
next question all right we gotta do last
question let's go to z
ap thank you all for doing this um i'm
just following up on jeff mason's
question earlier uh for you uh jeff
science
um on the uh uh these the additional
requirements
uh it seems what you're trying to do
here is impose some sort of cost on
people who are unvaccinated as a
the stick there to get them to roll up
the sleeves and get the shot
so why isn't the federal government
going further on some of these you know
whether it be mandating vaccination
requirements for travel
um across the federal workforce for
instance you know
how far is the administration willing to
go to sort of you know turn up the
pressure on the unvaccinated to actually
get
shots well zeke i think uh we've we've
taken
significant steps here uh to
to to make it difficult um
to come back to work or more difficult
to come back to work if you're not
vaccinated there's so many reasons to
get vaccinated that we've talked about
to protect yourself and to protect your
loved ones and it's also a really
straightforward way to return to work so
for all federal employees the path back
to work
if you're vaccinated is straightforward
if you're not vaccinated or you're not
willing to attest to
being vaccinated then you were doing the
right thing to protect
the workforce to protect the individual
their family and their colleagues
which is rigorous testing social
distancing
and masking there are mandates um
at the va for vaccination for their
healthcare workers their doctors
and their nurses and other health care
providers who take care of our
veterans that's consistent with a lot of
health systems across the country and a
growing number of health systems that
are requiring
vaccinations for their health care
workers who are on the front lines
as i said earlier the department of
defense
is looking into how and when they'll add
covid to the list of mandatory
vaccinations
for active duty military
at the same time we will continue to
look across the federal government at
other areas where
requirement requiring vaccines everyone
be vaccinated
may make sense particularly in the
health care setting
and we're seeing it in the private
sector more and more companies
are coming up with systems that are
modeled after
our system are similar to our system or
acquiring vaccinations across the board
you're seeing it at universities you're
seeing it health systems so i think that
this
requiring of individuals to be
vaccinated in order to come back to work
or to go back to school is a growing
trend
and makes a lot of sense given that
we're going to beat this pandemic
by getting more and more people
vaccinated
i want to thank everybody for today look
forward to the next briefing
thank you so that's certainly very very
different than when trump used to do
these
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something like that
by injection inside or
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous
uh very powerful light apply
light and heat to cure supposing you
brought the light inside the body
yeah we brought bringing the light in
all right so very very good and and i
think that very important briefing here
i'm glad that it was done
let's uh i still have other things so so
many people signed up
during this i want to thank everybody on
my website
jennifer emery became a new member
juan morales is a new member
kelly cole signed up darlene limpert
as well as mitchell dunn and gene
torres steve barnett and
angela slawney want to say thanks to
sanford wilcox as well as wednesday
adams
love it putting us at 33. over on twitch
new twitch prime subscriptions from
texas bear claw dino sorcal
richard eggel dan's news amraki gifted a
sub
snehal gifted a sub xavier signed up
sobe signed up queen sweet thang
and chief boris putting us at
40. wow now i said i had a game to play
if we got to 50 called noam chomsky
versus bobby fischer
we didn't get there but this is such a
great game
that i'm gonna actually jump in and play
a couple rounds of the game
i'm gonna take it on faith that 10 more
people are going to sign up
drop in those twitch subs get that
joinedpakman.com subscription you can
use the coupon code
my hipaa to save 70 just do it
just do it okay let's try this game out
the game is called noam chomsky or bobby
fisher we are going to put
a quote up on the screen and we have to
guess
was it gnome chomsky or bobby fisher and
then we will look at the video
first one if i had a minute with george
bush
i'd ask him if he's talked to god lately
so i think certainly it would strike me
as this being a bobby fischer quote but
maybe that's the trick
maybe it's actually a gnome chomsky
quote
because i could imagine george w bush
claiming that god did this for him and
god told him that
and god told him to go to iraq and maybe
it's a it's a political reference from
noam chomsky so although i think it's
it's obvious that it should be fisher i
think that it's noam chomsky
okay let's now pull up the video clip
and see who it was okay
uh-oh
[Music]
exactly the role that george bush plays
in this is very
dubious questionable in some cases like
say ronald reagan
he probably didn't even know what the
policies were he was reading off his
note cards of the teleprompter or
something like that
and bush may have some knowledge of them
but i think he's mostly a symbolic a
ceremonial figure
trained to act in certain ways and so on
so if i had
a minute with him i would say you know
have you talked to god lately or
something like that there it is so
first round is uh noam chomsky all right
very well
the game's working pretty well so far
guys i have to say
i do want to say thanks to a danish
joint bionic keyboard
the div and two gifted subs from
jen here putting us at 45. i think we're
going to get there
i think we're going to get there looks
like there's five people also in process
of signing up on my website
all right let's go to the next one was
it noam
chomsky who said it or was it bobby
fisher who said it
i don't think they should mess in in the
intellectual affairs you know what i
mean
they should keep strictly to the home
stay in the house cleaning things
they should just be at home waiting for
the man to come home
and that's all this has to be bobby
fisher right
there's no way that this is chomsky
people seem to say it was bobby fisher
that's my guess all right let's look at
it so so far
i'm one of one many people in chat wrong
on that first one
here we go i don't think they should uh
mess into in
intellectual affairs you know what i
mean you should keep
strictly to the home a woman's place is
over the hot stove
no they can't cook but they stay in the
house cleaning and things
what can they do well you know
just be at home waiting for the man to
come home with that
wow so that was bobby fisher
rightly guessed the game
is uh noam chomsky or bobby fisher
just because they have similar beards
we're not saying they're similar in any
way it's just a game guys okay it's just
a game
here's the last one it's time to finish
off the united states once and for all
death to president bush i say death to
the united states okay
this strikes me as something that fisher
would say
it doesn't strike me as something that
noam chomsky would say
that's my guess people in chat
seem to mostly think that that's
probably a bobby fischer quote
oh i want to say thanks to fearside for
the twitch prime sub number 46. all
right people saying
it is definitely bobby fisher uh let's
take a look
here we go this is all wonderful news
it's time for the
us to get their heads kicked in they're
trying to finish off the us once and for
all yeah
president bush i say united states
united states the jews the jews are
criminal people they mutilate their
children
they're a murderous criminal lying
masters they made up the hall of fame
not only was uh bobby fisher an
anti-semitic conspiracy theorist
i'm pretty sure he was also uh jewish i
think his mom
was jewish so that's the game guys i
have more of these but those were the
three i was going to go over now
i want to say thanks to hate to lose 112
who is uh
number 47 today um we have more but
we're going to we're going to play them
again in the future
we're going to play them again in the
future because i don't want to use all
of them today but that's the game
noam chomsky or bobby fisher bobby
fisher was
completely out of his mind also thanks
to hate to lose 112 for five
gifted subscriptions via twitch prime i
really do appreciate that
really really strongly very very strong
all right guys thank you for joining me
today
i will make every effort to stream
tomorrow that will be
my last stream for a little while
because i'm going to be on vacation we
will have guest hosts
farron cousins and jesse dollamore
um but i will look to see
folks again tomorrow alright thank you
very much for joining me